President Trump has announced plans to
end family separation at the border the
left must be thrilled right this is what
they've been asking for for months and
months and years and years but they're
not thrilled because President Trump's
immigration opponents never really cared
about family separation or detention
center conditions at all they just want
open borders we will examine how
President Trump called their bluff and
what it means for border security then
San Francisco politicians rebrand
criminals as justice-involved persons we
will practice the latest PC jargon
finally big news another 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate drops out and the
field drops down to only 722 or so all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
breaking news before we get to the other
news about family separation we have got
to get to this breaking news out of the
2020 presidential campaign Democratic
congressman Seth Moulton is no longer
running for president and in other news
Democratic congressman Seth Moulton was
running for president but now he is no
longer he is back to running for
re-election to his House seat he ended
his campaign with a warning this is what
he said quote I think it's evident that
this is now a three-way race between
Biden Warren and Sanders and really it's
a debate about how far left the party
should go I will say about Seth Moulton
I know that nobody heard about him but I
actually did because part of my job is I
have to figure out who all the
candidates are and look into them a
little bit and Seth Moulton was one of
the more moderate candidates he had
military service he was a little bit
more in the moderate lane of the
Democratic Party never took off never
went anywhere now he's gone he is
dropping out and you never heard about
him I think that kind of answers his
warning his warning is how far left is
the Democratic Party going to go the
answer is the only candidates who were
left are very left-wing
you've got Warren and Sanders who are
legitimately four left radicals and then
you have Joe Biden who has really
doesn't have any beliefs at all at times
in his career he's positioned himself as
a moderate at other times he's
positioned himself as a far left
candidate and for most of this
presidential campaign he has gone far to
the left
even now dropping his support for the
Hyde Amendment and endorsing taxpayer
funding for abortion so I it's a good
warning from Seth Moulton but we've
already got the answer the party is
going to the left we will get to the big
news though on the border and the Trump
administration's new immigration policy
but first I have got to thank our
friends over at zip recruiter you need
to find good employees you need to find
good quality employees we're doing that
right now in our presidential race we
the people are trying to find good
quality employees who could run for
president if only we could apply zip
recruiter to the presidency we would
not have the current field of candidates
that we do but a zip recruiter is
incredible sense your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards they don't
just stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one of
them and spotlights the top candidates
so you never miss a great match every
other job where just about you know they
it's pretty much like throwing spaghetti
at the wall maybe you never hear back
about the job maybe you do but you don't
know who's coming in zip recruiter is so
effective they are the best in the game
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
zipper goes out it keeps doing the job
for you to find the best candidates
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot-com slash Noll
scanner wles
that is zip recruiter dot-com slash Noll
scanner wles
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire so
other than Seth Moulton I'm glad you
have gotten your composure back from
this shock you know you've pulled your
cars off to the side of the road you now
know Seth Moulton is out of the race
let's get to the big news today which is
President Trump calling the left's bluff
on illegal immigration he is doing this
by ending the family separation policy
and he's doing that by ripping up the
Flores settlement agreement which in
1997 established the principle for
family separation nobody knows anything
about this in part because the our
immigration policy is so broken and
backwards and incomprehensible that no
one looks into it in part because
presidents of both parties have not
actually enforced immigration law and in
part because what the left wants you to
believe is that President Trump
instituted a family separation policy at
the border that's what they want you to
believe that isn't true the family
separation policy goes back 22 years at
least to the Flores Agreement now what
what President Trump is showing today is
that the left's arguments are
in good faith the left has been saying
they all they want to do is stop the
family separation but they don't care
about family separation they don't care
about the kids being in the detention
facilities they just want open borders
so here's what happened decades ago the
left said immigration enforcement cannot
detain children they can't do it
please government stopped detaining
children so what did the government say
okay that's fine they took the children
out of immigration enforcement custody
through something called the Flores
agreement then the left said wait a
second wait a second you can't separate
families you've got to stop separating
families so then President Trump and the
government said okay we'll stop
separating families they put them back
together now the left is saying you
can't detain children you're damned if
you do and you're damned if you don't
because what it's showing is that the
left once open borders here's how here's
how the left is reacting to Trump's new
policy which ends family separation
quote New York Times migrant families
would face indefinite detention under
new Trump rule New Yorker says quote the
Trump administration's sustained attack
on the rights of immigrant children
Miami Herald knew Trump administration
rule would let feds detain immigrant
children indefinitely Washington Post
Trump administration moves to terminate
the court agreement hold migrant
children and parents longer now a more
accurate headline would be Trump gives
the left exactly what they've been
asking for in family separation this
this proves that old rule be careful
what you ask for because you just might
get it
the left doesn't really care about the
family separation here is a quick
history of the left's immigration
argument you can just see just those
breezed through from 1985 to the present
how they keep changing how they keep
moving the goal posts how they keep
trying to hide their real goal which is
open borders and how they can no longer
hide it so beginning around 1985 two
left-wing organizations sued the I NS
which was the predecessor to ice that
was the old immigration enforcement and
they sued over the detention of illegal
alien children and this was litigated
for over a decade so goes through the
end of the 80s into the 90s
up until goes
all the way actually up to the Supreme
Court and then in 1997 the government
and these pro-immigration pro-v illegal
immigrant organizations come to a
settlement what does the settlement say
it says three things says the government
is required to release children from
immigration detention without
unnecessary delay and it goes in order
of preference being beginning with
parents and then two other adult
relatives as well as licensed programs
willing to accept custody if if there's
no one to grab them second thing the
settlement says is with respect to
children for whom a suitable placement
is not immediately available the
government is obligated to place
children in the least restrictive
setting appropriate to their age and
their needs so you're not going to throw
them in jail you're gonna put them in a
separate facility that's nicer and more
free and more liberated third thing that
the settlement says is the government is
required to implement standards relating
to the care and treatment of children in
immigrant detention that's why they're
not in jails which have actually in
America they have very good standards
but they're in facilities that are even
nicer they have teddy bears they get
pizza and juice boxes whatever all these
things I'm not saying they're staying at
the shangri-la or the ritz-carlton but
they're staying in relatively nicer
facilities as per this agreement now
what is not said in there but what all
of that means is the kids are separated
from their families because the families
are being held by immigration
enforcement but the agreement says the
kids can't be held by immigration
enforcement for that long so the kids it
as per the law you have to take the kids
and put them in two different and
ostensibly nicer conditions which means
taking them away from their families or
it means just releasing their parents
and letting them go right those are the
only two options you can have and what
the left and what Pro illegal
immigration conservatives and
Republicans want to do I shouldn't say I
don't think there are many Pro illegal
immigration conservatives but what Pro
illegal immigration Republicans and
libertarians want to do is say okay just
let him go just let him out right let's
not enforce the law and it was a sort of
unholy alliance between the left and the
Libertarians also the agreement wasn't
really implemented until a little bit
later until
Trump and until today the left admits
their real goals we'll get to that in a
second but first support for the Michael
Nolt show comes from our friends and
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans you
know that I live in Los Angeles it's
very difficult to find a house in LA
mostly because Shapiro pays me slave
wages and every house in LA costs like a
zillion dollars however when I do find a
house at least finding the right
mortgage will be easy because rocket
mortgage makes it easy their mortgage
experts number-one goal is to make the
home buying process smoother for you
it means industry-leading online lending
technology rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way for most people
buying a home is going to be the single
most important financial decision you
ever make in your life if you're like me
you're a millennial and you don't know
anything about anything practical like
getting a mortgage you know paying your
bills doing your taxes getting a
mortgage can be extraordinarily
complicated don't go in blind don't go
it alone go to the place with the
highest customer satisfaction for
primary mortgage origination 9 years in
a row highest in mortgage servicing five
years in a row when you work with them
you get more than just a loan because
rocket mortgage is more than just a
lender go with them guys I am Telling
You this is gonna be a huge decision in
your life don't go it without the best
get started online at rocket mortgage
com / Knolls que no wles Equal Housing
lender licensed in all 50 states and MLS
consumer access organ number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage so they come to this
Flores agreement in 97 that establishes
family separation except it wasn't
actually implemented through the end of
the Clinton era or through the beginning
of the Bush era it's finally implemented
in 2003 under george w bush when the
office of refugee resettlement takes
over unaccompanied minors then 2005 two
years later george w bush issues what he
calls a zero tolerance approach to
illegal immigration this is when finally
conservatives are gonna start taking
illegal immigration seriously right he
does it through a program called
Operation Streamline so they're going to
take it seriously except they don't they
don't what so what it means before is
that the DOJ
wasn't really prosecuting illegal
immigration all that much but even the
zero tolerance policy didn't really do
all that much why not because it made an
exception for illegal aliens traveling
with minors so if you what happens we
know how incentives work if you create
an exception to immigration enforcement
you've already got this big problem of
illegal aliens coming in you're going to
get more of the behavior that you're
incentivizing so when Barack Obama takes
over in 2009 he has an even looser
approach to illegal immigration he just
releases the parents so he has this
habit of releasing the parents who come
with the kids
what happens parents start flooding the
border with their children in 2014 you
had a major crisis President Obama
responded first by doing exactly what
what President Trump was doing when
President Trump was doing until just
recently which is separating the
families entertaining the kids and you
got a few photos out of this of the
so-called children in cages and what's
so unbelievable about the hypocrisy of
the left on this is when they're
protesting president Trump's immigration
policy they're sending around all these
photos on social media they went viral
of kids and cages but the photos aren't
from 2017 or 2018 or 2019 the photos are
from 2014 when Barack Obama was doing
the exact same thing
there was no hubbub when Barack Obama
did it they don't care because they
don't actually care about family
separation they don't care about quote
unquote kids in cages they just care
about pressuring a conservative
president to give us open borders
President Obama eventually just
basically let illegal aliens go and here
you get the policy of catch and release
so you catch the illegal aliens poring
over the border of this country but you
can't detain them for very long
especially if they have kids so since it
takes years to hear these asylum claims
you arrest them you bring them in and
then you just let them go because
they're gonna show up to their court
hearings right in a couple months or a
couple years right they're gonna show up
no of course not you let them go they
disappear they're in the country and you
have de facto for all intents and
purposes open borders then Trump gets
into office you start
actually enforcing the law he starts
actually enforcing the Flores agreement
the left throws a fit they say we can't
separate families even though that's
what the law says
so then Trump says okay we won't
separate families the left throws a fit
they say we can't detain kids this shows
the left hand the Democratic candidates
for president say with their words they
say they don't want open borders here's
who Leon Castro leading the charge open
borders just a right wing talking point
it always has been no I don't support
open borders we do have a problem with
southern border Democrats should not
deny that we don't nations should have
borders were should be respected in
closing nor the tornado bosses that's a
coke brothers proposal that's what they
say with their words actually the only
one of those who has sort of shown that
he doesn't want completely open borders
is Bernie Sanders because he says open
borders drive down wages but all the
rest of them have said with their words
they don't want to open borders and then
they call for decriminalizing border
crossings Cory Booker and who leon
castro both say we shouldn't treat
entering this country illegally as a
criminal matter now this is obviously
ridiculous this is open border so they
say one thing with their words at the
same time they are calling for getting
rid of our national sovereignty they're
calling for letting illegal aliens flood
into this country it's it's
mealy-mouthed language and what I love
about what President Trump is doing now
is first of all I'm glad that this
policy is not going to there is now some
workaround to separating the families I
mean the law was you had to separate
them now they're saying we're gonna rip
up the Flores agreement and we're gonna
detain parents with their kids if it's
really the if it's really the parents
and if it's really their kids in the
first place I think that's fine but they
are going to detain them there you can
either detain them together you can
detain them separately or you can let
them go and have open borders and of
those three options I'm glad we are
choosing the former I think that first
option is the best one
now the left either has to defend family
separation or open borders and they're
trying to have their cake and eat it too
they're trying to have both I love that
there's clarity on this this is a great
move it shows President Trump is finally
getting serious on
immigration enforcement after what two
years of not building the wall not one
inch of new wall
finally I've been saying this is a major
vulnerability for him in 2020 if he
doesn't get tough on it before then he's
gonna have a lot of trouble making the
pitch to his supporters it looks like
he's finally doing that and if he is I
cheer it on good on you
speaking of that mealy-mouthed language
though over in san francisco there is a
whole bunch of politically correct
language that has just come out from the
Board of Supervisors over there this
doesn't have to do with illegal
immigration necessarily this has to do
with crime generally in San Francisco
they announced in San Francisco has one
of the highest crime rates in the
country they announced that they were
gonna finally tackle the issue of crime
you know how they're gonna do it are
they gonna arrest the criminals no
they're gonna clean up the streets no
are they gonna enforce more laws and
pass more like no they're not gonna do
any of that they're just gonna stop
calling them criminals that'll do it
that'll do it
why didn't I think of that if you don't
call criminals criminals then you don't
have any more criminals right that's the
idea what they're going to start doing
them is changing all sorts of language
around this issue so juvenile
delinquents you know what the new that's
the bad term you can't bad kids you
can't call them that kids who commit
crime you can't call them that juvenile
delinquents you can't calling that the
new term is young persons impacted by
the juvenile justice system now
everybody is impacted by the juvenile
justice system everyone who lives in the
society is impacted by it because that's
the system to take bad kids out or
committing crimes drug addicts aren't
they're not drug addicts anymore
they're not even substance abusers which
was the new politically correct term
just a few years ago now they are
persons with a history of substance
abuse and then criminals and convicts
this is my favorite one of all criminals
and felons convicts they are now quote
justice involved persons this is my
favorite PC jargon of all because it is
actually the
opposite of the truth criminals are not
justice-involved persons criminals by
definition are injustice involved
persons they are committing injustice
not justices it would be like San
Francisco referring to their their
epidemic of drug and feces infested
streets as sanitation involved sidewalks
doesn't make a lot of sense but this is
what pc does you know instead of solving
the problem instead of grappling with
reality these politicians in San
Francisco think that they can just
change the name because it's a lot
easier think about how the left did this
they've done this for years and years
and years Barack Obama runs for
president 2008 he says he's going to end
these wars in the Middle East so he gets
into office does he end the wars no he
actually launches more wars in the
Middle East but he doesn't call them
wars he calls them quote overseas
contingency operations so there you go
that's one way to end a war you just
stop calling it a war and then it's not
a war anymore right they do this with
illegal aliens with millions and
millions at least 11 million probably
many more foreign nationals
illegally living in this country how are
we going to deal with that problem we
could either deal with the actual
problem or we can do what the left does
which is just pretend that they're not
foreign nationals we can use the term
undocumented Americans which has now
been adopted by a lot of left wingers so
there's no more foreigners in the
country right because they're not
they're undocumented Americans so they
can't be foreigners right same thing I
mean the biggest cultural issue of the
day even though it only affects a small
number of people it dominates our
discourse transgenderism instead of
actually getting help for men who are
confused about their biological sex the
left just uses PC language to rebrand
them as transgender women so now they're
not men who have a problem a
psychological problem they're just
they're they're women kind of in a way
with the language this kind of PC jargon
is offensive to language I mean it's
offensive from a linguistic point of
view but it's also just offensive to
people if I were in San Francisco I
would be really upset because you elect
politicians
to reduce crime you address them to do
what you want them to do you address you
elect them to pass policies that will be
good for your community but it's hard to
do that you have to make difficult
decisions you have to show leadership
and courage and moral vision and the San
Francisco politicians don't have any of
that so instead what they're doing is
they're just pretending the problem
doesn't exist at all this was a huge
reason that people voted for President
Trump in 2016 they voted for him for the
border they voted for him for the
economy they voted for him for trade
they vote sure largely I think they
voted for him because he came out and he
said political correctness is killing
this country and I'm not gonna be
politically correct I don't have time to
be politically correct I talked to
people even before I like Trump in the
primaries back when I was I was
supporting Ted Cruz I would talk to some
of my friends I say we love Trump I'd
say I'm skeptical of Trump I don't know
he's donated to Democrats he seems like
a little bit liberal wise talks kind of
funny I'm not sure that I support Trump
they said we need Trump because Trump
will defeat political correctness so
what what does that mean I don't elect
politicians for those cultural reasons I
like them for policies but my friends
were right political correctness is so
awful it's just lies it's just deception
when people use politically correct
jargon they are just trying to deceive
you they are using soft euphemisms to
confuse you about difficult concepts
that they want you to swallow whole
premises they want you to take over this
is a real danger to the country you know
when people use that you've got to be on
your guard there no criminal is going to
be reformed by you pretending is not a
criminal we have 10,000 prisoners
getting out of state and federal prisons
every day in this country we should
reintegrate them into society we should
prevent them from going to prison in the
first place one way we could do that is
by starting at home fixing broken
families you have huge rates of single
parents huge rates of out of wedlock
birth and people who were raised in a
home without a father are multiples more
likely to commit crime to end up in
prison tackle those issues that
it's not as easy as changing language
but that's what we're electing people to
do that's what we're here in this
country to do turning to other big news
this actually does matter in terms of
politics even though it's a minor news
story it seems libertarian billionaire
and political funder David Koch has died
of cancer he is one of the Koch brothers
and speaking of leftist deception it is
unbelievable how his death is being
covered in that left-wing media in the
mainstream media shows you a lot about
how the left perceives anybody even
slightly to the right of them David Koch
was a billionaire libertarian he was a
major philanthropist he gave 1.3 billion
dollars to charity over his career and
leftists from Hollywood types to pundits
to CNN contributors or celebrating
cheering on his death some idiot from
slate Jordan Weissman said that he hopes
that David Koch soul suffers for
eternity some alleged left-wing comedian
has I don't remember her name she has
like a million Twitter followers she
joked about how Koch was a Nazi they
don't even know who David Koch is David
Koch wasn't that conservative he was a
libertarian he really loved individual
liberty in some ways he was even kind of
a left libertarian he's supported
abortion he supported redefining
marriage he supported stem-cell research
he supported decriminalizing drugs
he supported non interventionist foreign
policy he sat on the board of the Cato
Institute and the reason foundation he's
a libertarian outlets they don't care
they call him a Nazi I mean David Koch
was actually the opposite of a Nazi
right he's a complete libertarian even
the usual issues that the Left uses to
try to call us Nazis and portray
conservatives as Nazis don't apply to
David Koch because he was actually
pretty liberal on a lot of issues what
it shows you doesn't matter what
concessions you give the left doesn't
matter if you try to be really nice or
you give them one issue or you give them
this issue or you're a good guy or you
give a billion dollars to charity how
much of any of his critics ever given to
charity like nothing I bet doesn't
matter it actually does tie in a little
bit to what we were talking about
yesterday about the people who are
conservative but not that kind of
conservative you know the people who
they're sort of conservative but they
they agree with the left on some things
and they want the left to like them
now I'm not accusing Charles Koch of
doing that Charles Koch was his own man
he believed what he believed he was a
rock ribs libertarian and didn't pretend
to be otherwise but the way the Left
treated him the way they smear him is
anybody to the right of I don't know
Hillary Clinton now anybody to the right
of Joe Biden is some kind of Nazi awful
- there's no way that you are ever going
to get their approval or their love so
you can be like coke and you actually
just be a libertarian and go out do what
you believe and not really care what
they say about you or if you are a
conservative get the lesson stop sucking
up to the left they are not going to
like you we have to get to speaking of
fake news speaking to the way the left
deceives not just with language not just
with the opposite of eulogies not just
with their celebrations and dancing on
grapes but with the coverage of a major
news story that is so false over in the
Amazon before we get to that I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
by the way The Daily wire has turned
four years old and we are thrilled as a
thank you to our fans we are giving away
one month of our premium monthly
subscription to anyone who uses the code
birthday now you can do that right now
we we absolutely support thank you
rather for all the support you have made
us get to four years we couldn't have
done it without you we want to thank you
with that so if you haven't subscribed
yet go on over you'll get a month free
and it's a lot of fun we got a lot of
stuff behind that pay wall and of course
you can get your leftist tears tumblr
with an annual subscription head on over
to daily wire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
okay I want to get to this story about
how the Amazon is burning the Amazon
rainforest it's gonna burn to the ground
we're not gonna have any oxygen we're
not gonna have any more wildlife in the
whole world it's terrible and it's all
being caused by conservatives somehow
I'm not quite sure how or it's being
caused by global warming or something
and it's never okay this is the
narrative that you're seeing pray for
the amazon national leaders Emmanuel
macron in France Merkel in Germany all
talking about this largely based on fake
news so we'll get to that in a second
but first my pal Charlie Kirk stopped by
Charlie Kirk is the head of the students
for Trump he is the head of TV USA he is
always on an airplane flying around
rallying young conservative support all
around America he came by in LA and so
we did a sat down for probably 35 40
minute interview you will be able to get
that tomorrow we're gonna release that
but I wanted to give you just a little
bit I'm in six or seven minutes of it of
sitting down with Charlie Kirk
incredibly interesting guy so we'll get
to him and then we will get to the
Amazon jungle it occurs to me you're
speaking obviously very in religious
terms and this is traditional for
conservatives especially in that
post-war conservative movement you had
the libertarians the traditionalists a
religious right you had the communism
Hawks
they were all against this this common
enemy which was the Soviet Union the
cold war ends then what what does the
conservative movement look like such a
great question so the the Soviet Union
kept them all together is what that's
why Reagan was able to build this
coalition in 1980 and take over the
party that he wasn't supposed to ever be
the nominee of right I mean in 76 Reagan
tried to overthrow sitting president
Gerald Ford in 1976 and he got to the
convention floor and sort of half
endorsed him didn't really endorse him
but Reagan was a rebel and the reason
why rate people thought Reagan was gonna
lose in a landslide to Jimmy Carter and
he won surprisingly sound familiar
hmm and then all of a sudden he was the
one that crushed the Soviet Union so
what is our Soviet Union today well it's
the left in our country the Soviet
Union's no longer headquartered in
Moscow there in Montana Michigan
Mississippi and Missouri
they're everywhere and only on the
university campuses right well it's the
center and then I'm in Hollywood and all
this other so so look the the coalition
that we have to build though yeah that
Reagan got correct and Trump gets
correct and I feel that our movement
gets wrong so often is we have to break
and you understand is we have to break
our shackles away from these coastal
elitist than at universities and these
think tanks that think that if you're a
carpenter a pipe fitter or you didn't go
to four-year college or somehow less
than worthy to have be engaged in the
American conversation right that's what
Reagan was successful that's where Trump
is successful and I feel as if there's
this elitism that permeates our movement
where all of a sudden that if you didn't
go to the correct University in the
upper Northeast Corridor right any
opinion you have is what
well it's deplorable it's all this and
the left says it our people don't you
know what it is it's also an emperor has
no clothes in the situation because
having gone to one of those correct
universities in the Northeast Court and
I did you go to one of them and you
didn't go to one of them I didn't go to
any you didn't go to any of them but you
do have an honorary degree yes from
Liberty University everybody should go
to the University yes but you know
having gone there I can kind of see
what's happened to it what the left has
done to these universities which is to
hollow them out from within so it's not
to say that there's nothing to be gained
at any of these places but what it is to
say is the institution that's hobbling
around and it looks like Harvard or Yale
and it talks like Harvard or Yale it
isn't what it used to be the left has
gone on a long march through the
institutions and so what you are getting
in the end is something that's simply
not as academically serious scholarly
scholar Lilly rigorous you're not
getting that same quality of education
so you have whole generations who are
uneducated uncultured they're so damned
convinced that they're the smartest
beyond that they're hyper credentialed
hyper credentialed so they have all the
degrees but they know nothing right and
they often have a lot of student debt
right so they're they're they're in debt
they're vulnerable and they have degrees
up the wazoo and they there's no wisdom
there's no knowledge there's no history
no perspective no humility no definitely
not they're constantly wrong but they're
never in doubt that's exactly and so so
you you mix all this together so look
here's what the movement
in four it is number one we have to
dominate in the Libertarians I know you
know I might not see eye to eye on all
this a little I'm a little less liberal
but I I do see the point do we I mean
this is my question - sure do we need to
hold together the exact same cold no we
have to rebuild a new one okay and so my
coalition is number one I think we have
to libertarians I think those are ours
to get these guys hate government the
personal freedom and there's converse
there's robust conversations we can have
but all that sort of stuff
there's stuff that we should not
compromise on so like a pro-choice
libertarian sorry not gonna happen
right like if you want to go put some
substance in your body that I've never
done and I don't even know where to find
go ahead like I don't care right so
there's long as you have some to share
yeah what you know you know I'm saying
so that that's one libertarians those
are our people
okay we shouldn't lose that number two
is is any sort of person that goes to
has religion as a core part of their
their their day or their their life
their identity that that's these are our
people
yeah okay and they should be actually
four or five number three the other part
of the coalition is people that wake up
before 7:00 a.m. I'm not kidding every
human being in America that wakes up
before 7:00 a.m. should be a Republican
well that's good and then we should
limit the vote to be over at about 8:00
a.m. and then we win there I'm not good
and I say that somewhat jokingly but if
you're getting up early and you really
got a you got a really muster some
strength to go to work you're you're one
of us I don't care if you're a carpenter
a teacher a pipe fitter you're not a
left this Steve in a hedge fund manager
no okay of course but again there's
there 50 of them okay that's fine
but I'm talking with 50 thousand
teachers in a jury that we've never
talked to and they're working their tail
off right I think I'm this comes to this
hyper elitism so if you're waking up
early and you've got a really fight and
you got a your are people like that's I
want our party yummy the world the hard
work nation party that's us the final
thing is is the doctrinaire
conservatives and and there's about
eight or ten million of these people and
they're the ones that listen the band
they listen to Rush and you know they're
the tea party folks they buy all the
books those are our folks I love those
people right and that's our coalition
okay if you combine libertarians which
are generations coming in grease and
libertarian religious hard-working
conservatives that's 65 million people
you'll win any
election you can with that let them go
after all the people that was sleep
until 10 and do whatever the hell they
want it like I don't care about those
people right I do care about them I
don't care about their votes like I
don't wanna build a cook let me make
myself good I care about them as people
I don't like I don't want to build a
political party around people that sleep
all day and do nothing
of course yeah and they're not really
reliable when you need to go out and
knock on doors so you know what I'm
saying it's right that that's a movement
I think that can have robust debate and
can be and could be one that can win the
future and make our country a better
place now you know we're gonna have the
rest of the interview out tomorrow so
you can check it out I know Charlie
really likes the coalition of people who
wake up before 7:00 because that guy
never sleeps he is just the biggest ball
of energy I have ever seen he's like
bouncing off the walls one time I think
I might have been the first time I met
him I was in a fox greenroom in LA and
it was 3:30 or 4:00 in the morning and
I'm there you know cuz the East Coast
Fox & Friends is on the west coast it's
4:00 a.m. and so I'm sitting there I'm
like half asleep kind of drooling I've
got like a spresso stained on my face
charlie bounces in he comes like
bouncing off all the walls he's like hey
buddy my cologne I see above you you
know so it's great I really always love
talking him he's got a great vision for
the future of the country talks to a ton
of young people Jen's E and Millennials
all over so go check it out we had a
really great time before we go I want to
talk about this story out of the Amazon
you've probably heard from the
mainstream media you've seen it on
social media that the Amazon rainforest
is burning to the ground there's no it's
basically there's no more Amazon jungle
left it's all gone and it's caused by
Republicans and conservatives and global
warming or something right this is an
example of a lie getting all the way
around the world before the truth has
the time to put its pants on you know
the actual quote that that line is based
on is from Jonathan Swift and that the
line is falsehood flies and truth comes
limping after it and that's what's
happening the truth is coming limping
after hear and it's too late because the
images have already penetrated what is
true it's true that parts of the Amazon
or on fire it's even true that humans
are likely causing that fire those
but parts of the Amazon catch fire all
the time people burn parts of the
forests I mean you kind of regularly
have to do that and then people are
doing it also to clear some land to
raise meat and other things most of what
you're seeing on social media the photos
of the fires are not actually of the
current fires some of those are 30 years
old some of the pictures you're seeing
are fires and forests that aren't even
the Amazon one photo is from last year
one photo is from 20 years ago one of
the prominent photos is from 1989 what
this social media hysteria is really
about is not about the Amazon having
some fires
it's about leftist opposition to
president bowl Sonora who's a
conservative sort of Trumpets figure who
was just elected in Brazil we're seeing
the exact same thing in the United
States on the exact same talk topic we
were talking about at the top of the
show left wing pundits celebrities news
outlets constantly spreading around
these photos of the kids in cages Mitch
and those photos of the kids in cages
it's true there are some children who
have been detained illegal aliens who've
come over and have been detained it's
true that there are photos of this but
the main photos going around spread even
by news outlets are from 2014 when
Barack Obama was doing it and yet
they're blaming it on truck because the
social media frenzy is not about kids in
cages the social media frenzy is not
about the family separation policy the
social media frenzy is about leftist
opposition to President Trump there are
a few good lessons to take away from
this one context matters people I think
in politics people just want these they
make these grand statements that are
supposed to be eternally true that are
always at their logical extreme and
that's just not how politics works
politics is about context it's about
circumstance politics literally is just
how men relate to one another in the
city how they relate to one another in
civil society that's the first lesson
the second one is it's good to keep
perspective in politics whenever I see
something that's supposed to be some big
outrage I take a breath whenever
I read some reported the Trump tweet oh
no the tweet the world is gonna end I
just just take a little breath whenever
I see even something that is I don't
know the worst leftist doing the worst
thing imaginable I look at it I say okay
take a breath and I'm gonna see what
this actually means because that's what
propaganda is is when people on either
the left or the right or from any
political point of view are using
information and images to get a reaction
out of you and I don't want to be played
like that
sometimes I you know I give these
college lectures at the universities
around the country and I get all these
crazy things being yelled at me by
leftist students and I stay pretty calm
or if I go and do a debate on TV or
something like that I usually stay
pretty calm and the reason I stay pretty
calm is not because I have some
superhuman power to resist leftist
hysteria it's because I realize this
important lesson number two perspective
matters in politics people are
constantly trying to emotionally
manipulate you in politics that's pretty
much the definition of politics you need
to keep perspective just for your own
self-preservation third thing you got to
believe here third lesson don't believe
everything that you see on the internet
or that you hear on the internet that's
kind of I'm telling you on the Internet
not to believe everything you hear on
the internet but you know look it up see
what I'm talking about googling this is
very important you always see this meme
going around of Abraham Lincoln and it's
an old photo of Abraham Lincoln you know
from the 1860s and it says don't believe
everything you read on the internet
because often it's lies Abraham Lincoln
right and that this kind of shows you
that I mean every time I see a quote on
the Internet
I googled the quote probably seven or
eight times out of ten it's a spurious
quotation the person who said it didn't
really say it I saw it today
there was a quotation going around from
Thomas Jefferson he never said it he
said something that was sort of like it
but he never said it this is true of so
many Churchill quotations Abraham
Lincoln Thomas Jefferson George
Washington John Adams just look him up
don't believe everything be a little
skeptical now I'm probably preaching to
the choir because if you're listening to
this show
you're probably a little bit
conservative maybe you're a centrist or
a Democrat but you've got a conservative
bent to you and so you're probably
naturally skeptical the left is
naturally gullible and I think it's why
they fall for all these kind of things
you shouldn't fall for it always be
skeptical another great thing heading
into the weekend go check out my
interview with Charlie Kirk tomorrow a
great little article in The Wall Street
Journal that I really enjoyed it this
morning was from Peggy Noonan Peggy
Noonan was a speechwriter for Reagan and
then for Bush and she writes in the
journal and her the thing I loved about
this column is it's not about politics
and it's not about immigration it's not
about trade and it's not about foreign
policy it's about a bigger long-term
issue that is hurting our country which
is rudeness people are just rude they
don't have manners
and it's ties in with what we were
talking about on political correctness
because what the left wants you to
believe is that political correctness is
politeness but it's not political
correctness is not polite at all
political correctness is lies and lies
are never polite lies are very impolite
you know I pointed out I was on a Fox
show earlier today and I said political
correctness is so crazy because they'll
attack you for using basically the same
word and then they'll praise you for
using the same word so if I say a person
is colored he's a colored person that is
horribly offensive you cannot possibly
say that word today however if you I I
say that someone is a person of color
that is the right term that is not only
an acceptable term that is the preferred
term if you say anything else you're
terribly offensive they're the same
thing it is exactly 100% the same to
call someone a colored person or a
person of color but what the censors do
on the politically correct left is they
say one is horrifically bigoted and
offensive the other one is polite which
one is which I don't know you can barely
keep track politeness is different the
lightness is not using language to
pummel somebody to control somebody to
shut somebody up politeness is taking
care for people and being kind to them
tipping
holding the door open referring to
someone as mr. or mrs. this is something
that has been completely lost you know
it reminds me how in a traditional
culture where we have traditional
religion traditional culture and
traditional politics things make sense
and then when we say our politics is
awful we have to deconstruct it we have
to get rid of it we have to oppose it
we're being oppressed our culture is
oppressive our religion is oppressive
you get rid of all of it right we've
been doing this now for at least 50
years it's not like you just have
nothing then because human beings need
politics we need culture and we have a
religious longing for God so instead
when you have that vacuum it just gets
filled with nonsense so when you get rid
of politeness which you get is political
correctness and then it's so awful it's
so gross and corrosive so give it a read
in them you know be polite check out the
interview tomorrow with Charlie in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show I'll see you soon
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy bori our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Dany D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup by Jesuit Elvira production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everyone
is Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know the saying go woke
go broke man I hope that's true
but America's top CEOs are now saying
that businesses have to stop thinking
about business so much and do some of
that virtue stuff they've heard so much
about we'll talk about it on the Andrew
Clavin show I'm Andrew